oh my god i want to introduce you to
some other amazing filmmakers here
Beatrice pump spreading my producer Eli
Aronson my cinematographer Spencer
cubase and the amazing editor Daniel
maderos the production designer Brenda
Lizabeth Peters and Martin Horvath the
writers with me between this and this
and this I need to say thank you to the
Academy for allowing me this opportunity
to say thank you to the Academy this has
been a dream of mine since I was
probably four years old and I saw it's
kind of embarrassing these'll be Tamils
the Ten Commandments and it it's my
grandmother Paula pesca who was polish
and who survived and not the
concentration camps but labor camps in
Siberia when I was four started sewing
me costumes so I could dress up in
strange polish outfits and she sewed me
curtains for a theater that I put over
our garage and she told me her stories
of surviving the labor camps and survive
in the war and those stories and my
child's imagination grew into like the
Ten Commandments they grew into these
epics these stories larger-than-life
these fantastic stories and as I grew
older that friction between the reality
that she endured and that so many
unfortunately in different circumstances
continue to endure and my understanding
and imagination of that world that
friction really bothered me and that's
what led me to make this film all these
voices with Martin over there we
traveled listening to Metallica and some
polish tango from Slovenia up across
Europe to Auschwitz and and saw there
and actually filmed some there and
across tues Amish Poland which is the
the town that my grandmother and my
family my father side came from and when
I went to her door
of a beautiful blue house and this total
fairy tale of a world in front of her
Dora turned around and there was a stage
and I was like oh this is a strange sign
that I must be on some right path and
now I'm on another stage here in front
of all of you and I'll take this as a
sign that I should hopefully continue
doing what I'm doing and what would I
love to do so again thank you very much
and I'd also just like to thank these
wonderful people who made this possible
for me I'd like to thank all of the FI
and the community and so many mentors
that I've had that have guided me along
this way and many of them are here I
have to thank the rest of my family and
my mother's side and my father who were
here and my sister and my sister's wife
and my sister Marissa who's not here but
hi Marissa I told you i would say hello
and of course my wonderful girlfriend
live yeah this could I I'm not Danish
but I'll same danish and a kodak and afi
for allowing me to shoot on film this
film was a great opportunity and really
again to the Academy for letting me
screen that film with you all I'll be
quiet now thank you so so so so so so
much I want to say one last thing there
was one other person a lot but my great
uncle Moishe who was a builder and he
was some say is the reason to my family
survived the war and my father's side
and I want to interview him once and I
live private chef and doing a bunch of
other nonsense and he said okay you're
doing these other things but what are
you building and i love the belief that
film is something to build and i believe
the Academy believes that as well so
again thank you thank you thank you